hi there steve coffin here
[Music]
today i'm going to continue on this
whole subject of exploring the cultures
and the histories of of the you know the
people and the language group that we're
studying
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
uh you can tap or click on the bell to
get notifications and uh i welcome you
to come and join me at link
where i learn languages
so
i'm now of course doing my persian i'm
doing a little bit of mini stories not
too much because i've listened to them
so often i'm kind of tired of them but i
know they do me good it's like having a
workout in the gym
working certain uh you know core muscles
because they're the core structures but
then the core structures will show up
elsewhere as well so i'm kind of
spending most of my time now on the
history of iran 26 episodes
by uh sahra who is our
collaborator in iran
and i like listening to her voice
and so
the um you know one of the questions
that comes up is
you know
uh
are you do you get a better
understanding of the country the history
etc
if you do it in the language as opposed
to doing it say in english or french or
a language that i'm more comfortable in
so i gave that some thought
and
i kind of break it down this way
uh it's always easier for me to read in
english and and
then in most languages possibly with the
exception of french
which i can read quite comfortably
in spanish i mean those are easy to read
anytime you're in a different writing
system like japanese chinese russian
it's just a little more difficult
because you're you haven't read as many
millions and millions of words in those
writing systems as you have in in your
you know most familiar writing system
uh
so it's easy for me it's instant meaning
i i can leave for the book i get it i
it's instant meaning so that's always
easier
than reading about the country
say in chinese which i read fairly
comfortably
or let's say in persian which i don't
read very comfortably it's easier to
read in english
but what i found is
if you can listen to an audiobook about
the history
and i have done this
even historical novels like
ipromessi sposi in italian you know i
like these
but listening to the history of russia
the history of ukraine
uh the history of poland i've listened
to in polish now hearing the history of
of pur of iran fortunately sort of
simplified for me because sahara has
produced this wonderful series with
audio and text and circling questions so
it's it's digestible but digestible but
still it's the fact that i'm connecting
there is resonance there i am connecting
with
the country the history the language
and that it gives me a level of depth of
sort of resonance that i don't get in
the book if i'm looking for information
i want to find out what happened you
know sahara talks about
you know because each one of her
episodes deals with a different dynasty
so it's the 15th century the mongolian
invasions or the uh
sava feed or sasanian or whatever period
if i really wanted to delve into that
and get more in-depth knowledge i would
probably end up reading in english and
in fact someone on twitter and even a
person here recommended a book on the
history of iran and i have actually
ordered those from kindle so i will be
reading those in english
but
listening to it
is a degree of resonance now it has to
be well narrated it has to be by a
person with a pleasant voice
and good quality sound
very often that means a professional
narrator an audiobook and i have behind
me tons of audio books uh
czech history you know the chesky rose
class had
which was a history of of the czech
people within the austro-hungarian
empire holy roman empire whatever
um
so that i love doing
but i cheat because to really
catch up on what happened in those
histories i end up reading in english
because it's it's just that much easier
um
so
but the connection it brings you closer
that
and especially and this is another
important point i think a lot i
stress listening i always say i spend
most of my time listening someone asked
me how much time do i spend reading
every day
well you know i probably listen an hour
between working out and cleaning up and
so forth
but the reading say on my ipad in link
is maybe
30 40 50 minutes a day but i also read
another half hour or more in english
today
uh
but the
when you're listening you know it's so
very important that the voice that you
like the voice that the voice has a
resonance
i still remember some of the
uh
books i listened to say ukrainian
history i can't even remember the
professor's name but
he had a wonderful sort of
there was a certain
whether it was the intonation of the
voice it was pleasing and so it's very
important
and and that's where very often
the audio that accompanies
texts teaching
whatever it might be even persian or
japanese
english
french if it isn't if there is no
resonance if it's not pleasant to listen
to
then it's
you know that kind of defeats the
purpose so in a way reading is for
information reading is to find out more
about the culture of the history and so
forth
and the listening is for the connection
the resonance the emotion
that ties you to the language and gives
you that sense that you're sort of
participating
so i hope that explains it
so i i still think we rely on reading in
our own language uh in order to cover
more ground and learn more about the
country and and when we're reading in
our own language you're not even
conscious of reading it's just meaning
uh whenever you're reading in a foreign
language you're sort of
to some extent you're sub-vocalizing
your
kind of parsing you're looking up words
it just takes much much longer
i know
say when i'm going through the
history of iran and sentence by sentence
in sentence view at link
i turned on the google translate
bang i got the meaning right away
now i go word for word through the
you know farsi the persian and it takes
much much longer it's it's a bit of a
journey across going of course right to
left
across all those words looking at the
odd one i don't know
even if i know them all it takes me much
longer to read it whereas
the meaning in english is just there
however the listening the listening is
what i take away with me that i hear
over and over again i hear the same
uh words over and over again and they
gradually become part of me because i
hear them and i hear them uh
you know in a voice that is pleasant to
me so
there you have it
you know your own language the target
language to explore the culture the
history of the country the pros and cons
of each
thank you bye
[Music]
you